and this morning's ion money a new
report shows just five coastal cities
are getting a huge majority of America's
itec jobs
researchers found Seattle San Francisco
San Jose San Diego and Boston areas
accounted for more than 90% of the job
growth in the tech sector from 2005 to
2007 teen CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here to show us what the
what that says about the economy and the
future of jobs
Jill welcome happy birthday yesterday
thank you what let's start with this
what why is it why is it concentrated in
such small in a few areas you know these
are innovative industries and they have
found that clustering in these small
areas gives them access to a very highly
educated pool of talent they get to the
sophisticated supplier chain and
education is institutions and they
actually say that putting these areas in
sort of a small concentric circle allows
those companies to be more productive
and that's why they are settling in
these cities but why those areas as
opposed to North Dakota south because
well I think that those cities really
those cities have that great combination
and I think the problem is cities that
are select yeah and I think the problem
is that you see it in a lot of these
cities that there is a real downside to
this clustering effect first of all as
you said some of the smaller cities they
miss out on it yeah but also think about
this that sky-high housing prices have
created huge issues there are
infrastructure problems so
transportation and traffic and there are
social issues like homelessness which
have become really important with these
cities you end up with a division in the
country too though so because you've got
all these jobs concentrated in one area
you've got the haves and have-nots
extension these are high paid jobs
absolutely and what's what's interesting
in the report is that they say that
there's a fix to this and and stay with
me here because there's going to be some
consternation when you hear this they
believe that we as a country should
invest in some of these smaller cities
that are interior cities we should pick
10 maybe 20 cities we should invest a
hundred billion dollars as a con
trace of federal government spending
over ten years and try to fuel growth in
those areas because this is what's
missing we want this to be spread out it
is actually better for the economy you
see people loading up the truck and
moving to Seattle San Francisco San Jose
and should they well I think the
important pieces we just had a Labor
Department report on Friday this is a
very select group of professionals and I
wouldn't just load up the truck yet we
found out that in fact we had job
creation 266 thousand jobs created in
the month of November it was spread out
all over but we are seeing some jobs
created in certain sectors so we know
that there's tech but there's also
healthcare right we also know that we
have transportation and warehousing and
financial activities and we are seeing
some spreading out but these jobs in
particular it's a fascinating statistic
from the report they represent just
three percent of all jobs but six
percent of total economic output so this
is where the growth lives a lot better
than a lot of jobs to indeed to
economies all right Thank You Jill